in previous videos we talked about the
dramatic turnaround in the 4th century
in terms of how christianity was treated
in the roman empire as you enter into
the 4th century it's persecuted by
diocletian but then constantine takes
power he's sympathetic to the christians
he even convenes them in order to unify
the christians to have a more unified
sense of what it means to be christian
in order to settle things like the aryan
controversy and he converts himself to
christianity and as we exit the 4th
century you have theodosius who makes
christianity the official religion of
the roman empire and then begins to
persecute other religions now what we're
going to do in this video is continue
the narrative and in particular we're
going to see how there's an evolution
between the church in the west and the
church in the east in previous videos we
already talked about how the roman
empire itself is initially administered
between
west and east and then that
administration becomes more and more
formal theodosius is the last emperor to
truly rule both halves they start
getting ruled separately and as you get
into the latter half of the 5th century
the western empire itself falls to
germanic conquerors
now in previous videos we talk about how
the emperors who rule from
constantinople consider themselves to
continue the roman empire they didn't
call themselves the byzantine empire as
we now call them they call themselves
the roman empire they consider
themselves roman emperors the west falls
as i just mentioned into a bunch of
germanic kingdoms
justinian is able to reclaim a lot of
the land formally lost in the western
roman empire
now there's some other interesting
actors we see emerging on this map
and once again we're now in the 6th
century
you have these dramatic tribes the
visigothic kingdoms here in modern day
spain and here in modern day france you
have the franks and the word france
really is referring to land of the
franks another germanic tribe
now
they are about to factor much much more
relevantly and when i say about i'm
saying over the next several hundred
years in this eventual division
culturally and religiously between east
and west
as i mentioned in previous videos
the division yes it will center on
notions of language in the west
especially in the church latin is used
in the east in the church greek is used
there are spiritual debates that we will
touch on in a few minutes but there's
also a power struggle you have the
byzantine emperor
seated in constantinople
you have the bishop of rome now known as
the pope really the pope of rome who
considers themselves more and more the
leader of all of christianity and their
argument there is look this is the
church that according to tradition was
founded by peter first amongst the
apostles
you have the patriarch of constantinople
and patriarchs of other significant
centers of christianity that say wait
hold on a second yes
bishop of rome you are very important
but we consider you to be first amongst
equals you don't have jurisdiction over
all of christendom together we have
jurisdiction and this was to some degree
the case under justinian and it was very
clear at this time that the byzantine
emperor was very powerful not just over
the temporal realm really referring to
the day-to-day material realm but also a
lot of influence on the spiritual realm
which was really supposed to be the
domain of the bishops or the popes or
the patriarchs this notion of the
pentarchy was codified in the justinian
law this idea that these five centers of
christianity really have extra weight
and collectively are really leading
christendom
now as i mentioned things get
interesting as we fast forward about 250
years
so let's go to the year 800.
so one thing you might notice is that
group in yellow the franks have now
conquered a lot more and they're
conquering it under the leadership of
charlemagne at the same time you see
this green over here islam has
dramatically spread from its founding in
the early 7th century all the way now as
we're as we're exiting the 8th century
to cover most of the middle east persia
bordering on modern day pakistan india
north africa and even going into modern
day spain at the same time
especially because of these islamic
conquests the byzantine empire and the
byzantine emperor is significantly
weaker
so you can imagine the pope in rome here
saying well who's going to protect me
especially from my political enemies now
charlemagne considers himself something
of a protector of christianity and pope
leo iii goes to him for protection and
charlemagne is able to actually provide
it
and in exchange or perhaps in thanks for
that the pope crowns charlemagne as holy
roman emperor
now what's significant about this is it
really
introduces a fourth actor here because
the title holy roman emperor was
intentionally given to say look now you
charlemagne you are the heir to the
grandeur of rome you are the heir to the
roman emperors now you might be saying
wait isn't that what the byzantine
emperors thought they were didn't they
think this was the roman empire and at
that time their emperor was an empress
it was empress irene of athens and so
once again this is creating further
tension they're using different
languages
latin versus greek you now have the
western pope recognizing a different ex
you could say roman emperor in
charlemagne the nature of the west is
becoming more germanic and using the
language latin while the nature of the
east is continuing in greek traditions
on top of that
what you have in the year 800 you're
actually in this period where you've had
several conflicts over this notion of
iconoclasm this iconoclasm movement you
could say started in 726 when the
byzantine emperor said enough of these
images of jesus and the virgin mary and
other figures of christianity in our
churches citing references in the old
testament saying that hey we shouldn't
have these images
and so this cataclysm or these
destroying of icons starts to begin
well the pope in the west they say hey
we don't think we have to listen to you
i am the bishop of rome i have universal
jurisdiction and then to add insult to
injury now in 800 you have charlemagne
being crowned holy roman emperor
now a thread further running through
this is something that we talked about
in a previous video this notion of
philoque
where in 381 the council of
constantinople they augment the nicene
creed where they say and we believe in
the holy spirit the lord and giver of
life who proceeds from the father well
in the west they add the latin term
foloque which means and the son and this
is touching on some of these notions in
the aryan heresy where where does the
holy spirit proceed from if the father
and son are really co-divine co-equal of
the same substance shouldn't the holy
spirit proceed from both rather than
just one while those in the e said hey
this isn't what we agreed to while those
in the west say hey we don't think it's
so important that you agree to things
because we have the seat at rome the
seat that was established by
peter